martinique la station du françois en
tout cas oui on a besoin de dons
entretenir le matériel comme ce bateau
qui est derrière
peut-être de deuxième catégorie et comme
tous ceux qui ont fait pato et le savent
il ya toujours des pièces à changer il
ya toujours de l'entretien à faire pour
qu'on soit le plus opérationnel possible
pour que lorsqu on nous appelle pour
n'importe quel cas on puisse partir de
suite on est en permanence en train
surveiller pour pato c'est l'outil
principal
les sauveteurs ces bénévoles comme vous
comme vous autres les autres généreux
souhaite ça j'avais dire pourquoi mais
parce que je pense que déjà c'est tous
des passionnés
alors ce n'est passionnés de la mer mais
tous ont envie d'apporter quelque chose
de donner quelque chose aux autres et
puis c'est une construction si
personnelle parce que le fait de donner
bénévolement aux autres sans attente de
retour
ça nous permet de nous construire ta
maman donc peut-être ce côté un petit
peu égoïste mais c'est tous des gens
généreux et ses skis rose que j'aime à
la snsm
c'est que c'est une grande famille de ce
côté là des gens très hétéroclite que
dans le milieu professionnel a en tout
cas dans la vie de tous les jours on en
est tous que sûrement jamais rencontré
mais il ya cette générosité quel que
soit le métier la classe sociale
tous se retrouvent pour aider les autres